hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast and keynote presentation
diagnostic management teams
implementation obstacles presented by
dr. Michael la posada a professor and
chairman at the Department of Pathology
in the University of Texas Medical
Branch in Galveston
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab rats is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions that you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation just click on that
question box and let us know you're
having any problems this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credit tab on the
top right corner of your presentation
window and follow the process for
obtaining those credits please join me
now in welcoming our keynote presenter
today dr. Michael Lamott Sado I will now
turn the presentation over to him
welcome sir well hello everyone and
thank you for inviting me to give this
presentation to so many of you I've been
in the laboratory medicine field for a
long time
through the mid 80s and I certainly have
watched it get more complex and more
expensive when I was a resident I
remember that as a specialist in
coagulation that people had very little
knowledge about which tests to select
and what the results meant and I had
recognized early on that there was
need for expertise somebody on the other
end who was there all the time 24/7 I
think gave you ants about your complex
case even if you didn't ask them
it would just be part of the process
like radiology that looks at all the
imaging studies so this idea which has
been around and gained momentum over the
years has been one that people
delivering really need and they're
recognizing that they can do so much
better for their patients if they have
an expert a true expert easily available
to them to help solve their diagnostic
question where's if you don't have the
right diagnosis you don't have the right
treatment so this is the first and most
critical step in the process now you
would think that this scale-up
of the die stick management team
wouldn't be straightforward if there was
a big clinical need but having started
the formal diagnostic management team
process at the Massachusetts General
Hospital when I was there and in the
mid-1990s there have been a number of
obstacles to it's big scale up
nationally this would have a big oven in
health care in America we rank somewhere
in the 30s globally with our health care
because we have problems that limit our
ability to get the right answer quickly
so we're going to talk about those today
in this presentation so I'm gonna start
with an introduction about what a
diagnostic management team or DMT is and
what it does so let's take a look we
have four decades gotten testers of
health it laboratories and then toss
them over the wall to treating
physicians and we hope that they
actually know what to do with it so
let me show you the picture you can see
us on the right the diagnostic experts
not unhappy paying values across the
wall like factor v leiden heterozygous
that green puzzle piece to some poor
treating health fighter who never really
learned the genetics of coagulation
how could he or she because there's too
much to know but yet it's critical to
understand how you're supposed to treat
this patient so maybe we need a
different way to approach this and that
shown on this slide where we the
diagnostic experts actually grab the
puzzle pieces and we're gonna put them
together that is we're gonna have to
read the clinical record we're gonna
have to understand what echocardiography
is and how it impacts this particular
case and what we're gonna do is to solve
the diagnostic puzzle there is no wall
we communicate with the treating
healthcare providers who can see more
patients so we have to be able to solve
this problem for whatever provider is
delivering the care which could be in a
rural site or it could be in the middle
of Manhattan so let's take a look at
what we've given in a medical record to
a well-intended very smart treating
physician we give them positive or
negative where we give them 13.1 and
they don't know what it means and here's
an example from the day before we
started our collation diagnostic
management team at Vanderbilt and I was
there from 2008 until 2014 so this is
2010 and I asked the chief medical
officer how he would look at these data
and he said I do what all the doctors do
I looked for the data with an asterisk
because those are the ones that are
abnormal I said do you have any idea
what the rvvg is it has an asterisk he
said I
have to look that up with Google so when
that expert in a hospital a chief
medical officer is using Google as the
main source of information the patient's
have no idea but really there are not
many places to go to get a quick answer
also we had to provide abbreviations for
test names and six characters which
meant that the PTT mixing study says p+
n o HR which means no doctor has an idea
what to do with that one so as as you
can see there is simply too much in the
record that is not used and all these
negatives are important as well so what
did we turn that into well this is the
next day July 1st and that very case was
interpreted by me and instead of getting
a bunch of numbers only they saw the
numbers of course but they also had
words that they understood under the
numbers just like they do in radiology
you can see the cat scan but what you're
really looking for are the words of the
expert underneath the cat scan that
tells you what they see so it says the
patient has an elevated PTT the PT is
normal they did a thrombin time at
Vanderbilt as a screening test probably
not necessary and then all of the
testing that followed was all
algorithmically driven we set it up so
that all the doctor had to do was say
work out my phone PDT or determine if my
patient has a hypercoagulable state so
we're asked answering questions just
like in a normal consult so the PT was
elevated we did the next study which is
a PTT mixing study and it's suggested
from the results that there was an
inhibitor to this process of coagulation
issuance blood so the most common for an
elevated PTT that does not correct in a
mixing study is called lupus
anticoagulant and the test that we do
to determine if there is a lupus Ana
called dilute Russell viper venom or
entire VVT there it is that was the one
that was positive and it indicated that
a lupus anticoagulant was present and so
the last paragraph says you have a
patient of SPRO long PTT is on the basis
of a lupus anticoagulant by the way it
doesn't make you bleed so don't
transfuse there's no reason you could
have neurosurgery with this thing in
fact we more worried more about clotting
than we do about bleeding so a lot of
people say they they have a diagnostic
management team but we had to come up
with a definition to really make sure
that it's not just a case conference
where we're talking about something that
happened weeks ago and is no longer
under active decision-making nurse thing
is that if you have a diagnostic
management team you have to meet
frequently and regularly and by
regularly that doesn't mean once a year
means that when cases come up if you
have to make a diagnosis within a day or
two then you have to meet that schedule
if you have a week to make a diagnosis
then maybe you could meet weekly but you
have to make the report and deliver it
before or during the time when treatment
decisions are being made so that is a
big differentiator from a case
conference
the third element for the definition is
that you can't just say positive or
negative you have to look at the chart a
factor v leiden heterozygous results in
a 26 year old woman on oral
contraceptives means something totally
different from a 96 year old woman who
has just had a stroke so you have to put
all of that in context so that when you
make a recommendation it makes sense and
of course you have to put it in the
medical record if you're walking people
through a microbiology laboratory and
say look at that look at that look at
that you have to realize that there
there are many people involved in the
care of the patient so if you just tell
the person who happened to show up in
the laboratory here's what we found you
not really helping the patient because
you have to make everybody who might
touch this patient not even in this
episode but maybe in the next episode
when they Nair the information that you
have generated so all those have to be
met to say I am a diagnostic management
team such a good idea why in the world
have we had to wait so long to make it
so they could just press a button and
get me and help them figure by a 12 year
old kid in Wyoming got a deep vein
thrombosis in her right leg and what to
do about it and how to evaluate the
success of her anticoagulant therapy so
we're gonna talk about four things and
they're gonna be highlighted as we go
forward so the first one has to do with
getting so here it is the payment
problem so oddly we can get paid by
insurance if that would work we could
get a fee-for-service just charge you
for providing the paragraph of
interpretation and recommendation or
maybe we could get a contract because
there's plenty of times when we deal
with say a commercial laboratory but we
develop a contract with them for some
better pricing so let's talk about each
one of these first this is pretty new
for insurance that they are not so
familiar about a DMT and what they do
and its value and and sit there's I
should say little history a patient
specific patient specific expert driven
interpretations of lab results clinical
lab results for a long time there
they're just not familiar with it I
certainly have had experience with it in
Massachusetts during the time that I
spent at the Mass General for the six
years I spent at Vanderbilt in Tennessee
and now here in Texas so so there's not
a lot of experience with insurance
companies paying for this and of course
they worry about abuse this has happened
some pathology
in in the United States had a friend who
worked in the emergency room and you had
several criteria to get paid by an
insurance company in a consult for
clinical lab tests and so they met the
letter of the law the the EB physician
said please interpret the troponin
results which of course the edy
physician should know because that's
something you see all the time and have
to handle the pathologist came down and
wrote positive for MI so therefore it
was a requested consult
there was an abnormality present the
troponin was high and there was a
written report which was three words and
you look at the letter of the law
presumably you can get paid for that so
I think that this concern has made
insurance companies uncertain about what
to do with this because in fact it could
be really valuable if it's done and and
helps get a quicker diagnosis so the
default of non-payment as a general
practice by in Chinese is usually the
way it goes and because the dmt
consultations are still new to medical
practice then and I'm I wouldn't be
surprised and I've not been surprised
about them now what about the fee for
service would it be possible that an
institution which has a send out budget
so therefore we send out a million
dollars worth of tests and if we send
them to a commercial laboratory they
they built us they don't built so we
could work like a commercial laboratory
except that what we're asking to be paid
for is not performance of the protein s
activity assay we are being paid to
interpret the protein s value which is
low at 35 percent in somebody who's
pregnant and therefore not at risk for
thrombosis in this setting so the idea
here is if an institution says goodness
we can save
five million dollars if we got a
diagnosis the day after mission as
opposed to four a lot I mean all these
stuff for a week while our local people
not necessarily the national experts on
these topics are handling the case so
that is the idea for this concept and we
realize that no institution no matter
how big no matter how many experts there
are you are not going to have experts to
come as a whole of diagnostic medicine
so we are going to have to put together
regional or national diagnostic
management teams for which payment is
provided so if you wanted to do ten
cases for example and do the Monday
through Friday you would get this as
maybe as the first interpreter and you
would get paid for this in a way that
would make you incentivize to continue
to do it so let's take a look at this
contract issue so a pathology practice
which may be just one pathologist or it
might be twenty that's ologists in a yep
healthcare can says you know we want to
do anatomic pathology but we're getting
all these questions about toxicology and
okay opiates and what to do with this
toxicology screen and we don't have
anybody on staff who can answer those
questions but our medical staff is
getting frustrated not answering those
questions and we don't want to hire
somebody who's specialized in the other
part of pathology which is the part that
touches everybody the clinical lab tests
and and because we're not gonna hire an
MD or a PhD into our practice we need
someplace to go so so the practice
sometimes it's so big I've seen
practices where they actually own their
own clinical lab what they don't have
though is the expertise tell you what
all those test results me
a pathology of a large one with a
national footprint has asked us if we
would contract with them and do all of
their interpretations that are not
straight anatomic pathology this can
range from genetics to infection the co
AG the transfusion medicine and they're
negotiating a fee with them and we will
provide Chris should this all come
together so that we will build a
practice and and we will bill for what
we do so I think that the idea of a
contract is certainly a way that many
pass out
she practices small or large can get
help with literally anything so let's
talk about the second problem the second
problem is who's gonna who's gonna lead
all these tMT's who's gonna read the
journals and and say I'm ready hit me up
with the first ten cases of the day so
the diagnostic management team leaders
you would think would have to know the
basic principles of their area so what
what what is a PTT mixing study for a
coagulation person they have to know the
technical and clinical matters about a
test so I would be able to say
comfortably I know what it means if the
if the PTT is 65 and in the PTT mixing
it corrects into the reference range I
also know about how the PTT mixing study
is done how much normal plasma is mixed
with patient plasma and I understand the
diagnostic importance of it so anybody
who is a DMT leader has to check all
those boxes so let's take a look at
where we've been in American may I just
say this is an American problem you may
know that in Western Europe which is
rated much more highly in terms of
healthcare delivery than the United
States by objective criteria how long we
live the quality of our lives has
has separate services for anatomic and
clinical pathology there there are two
disciplines there like medicine and
surgery that doesn't mean we should do
that it does mean that we can't ignore
half of it so what we've done in our
payment system for decades is pay for
anatomic pathology so therefore most of
the pathologists in training during the
time that they were on chemistry
microbiology clinical hematology all
those rotations
we're not attentive enough to be able to
say with confidence you're anti-nuclear
antibody is one the 640 and here are all
the serologies and this is what it means
so that would take that would take some
effort to go ahead and pick it all up
again
I think that's challenging when you're a
mid-career provider as a pathologist to
say goodness now we're up above 5,000
tests many of which are genetic I'm not
really interested in starting from
scratch again to find out what b-raf
v600e actually means even though at this
point the mutations and the specific
single nucleotide variations and all the
pharmacogenomics are so relevant to
practice in healthcare so I think
practically speaking it is hard if you
have not learned it it is something
you're gonna have to plan to do
systematically to gain knowledge if
you're finished with your training so
this is an issue in the US based upon
the way we have built
I think practically speaking experts are
limited in laboratory medicine and again
this is the bulk of diagnostic medicine
remember radiology is in this with
pathology but they also have a limited
number of things that they have to
interpret so when you have individual
items that require interpretation
pharmacogenomics what is C
to see 19 star to mean for you that can
be really important because you're not
sensitive to clerics and if you have a
stent and they give you plaques and it
doesn't work the way you're gonna find
out is you're gonna have another heart
attack and it would be a lot better to
do a test for pharmacogenomics to find
that absolutely to give you a drug that
works so these are all relevant things
they're present in real time right now
so here are the financials generally in
an atomic pathologist can earn about
three or four times what a clinical
pathologist can make the average amount
of debt that you have coming out of
medical school in America is a hundred
and forty thousand I think that from the
time I was in medical school where with
single-digit thousands to now these
ridiculous sums it had always been a
question about what is the impact for us
in terms of healthcare I think people
didn't recognize that the impact is that
goodness if you marry that person who
was sitting next to you and they have
about the same amount of debt that you
did I you could be in a situation where
you might have to pay off half a million
dollars and therefore what it means is
that your options for career selection
are limited because you have to do this
and so I think tuitions have had a big
impact on not having enough people in
laboratory medicine cuz it was in pain
and there's a large amount of debt so
the are there enough pathologists to
lead the mts and I think the answer is
no not now anyhow and remember we're not
going to serve the whole country or the
Southeast region of the United States
with one person there have to be
multiple people on service so why not
have as we're trying to do here in Texas
but still in the discussion phase have
three or four experts in pick your area
toxicology microbiology coagulation and
they take care of the cases so here's
here's an interesting fact about DMT
switch
I think is counterintuitive I've worked
at these three institutions amass
general Vanderbilt and Texas count
listed a relative size my number of
patients in the hospital by a number of
visits and I put on the far right the
number of diem T's by topic we have
separate topics for diem T's which
include the toxicology and microbiology
Co AG transfusion medicine we have one
for child abuse because some of the some
of the cases that we had in Co AG were
cases involving a subdural hematoma and
a child where the parent was accused of
a child kids at a bleeding desert and
and there are a few more and so we're
the smallest but yet we have six active
DM T's and the reason it is because it's
essentially considered part of your job
if you work here that is all our lab
directors have to make sure that the
blood comes in and the right number goes
out but they all have responsible for
making sure that the cases are
interpreted so which ones do we do here
it depends upon the expertise and
interest of the Lambert director so if
somebody's interested in endocrine it'd
be hard to interpret all the endocrine
tests well what about just the thyroid
well that's kind of a big thing - what
about the thyroid cases for women who
are pregnant there's a lot of question
about what all that means for t4 and t3
in pregnancy so you can have a DMT that
just looks at thyroid test abnormalities
in pregnancy or toxicology for pain
management so the idea is pick your area
you do all the cases in that area we
don't throw out the breast biopsies we
can't figure out in AP we give an answer
so that's the idea everybody picks what
they're interested in and this plan to
create national or regional diagnostic
management teams hopefully with experts
who pass a certifying exam so that we
are cons
that they have a high likelihood for
giving us the advice
needs to occur and and I would submit
after working in this field for a long
time that it should be independent of
the type of doctoral degree there very
few MD toxicologists and the ph.d
toxicologists know a whole lot and to
say that they are not helping the
patients is not true so we have to
figure so an example of service coverage
so I am put expert a let's say that's me
and I'm on service here in Texas and
I'll take the first ten cases they come
into a regional DMV and I'm only gonna
do this on Monday and Tuesday I think I
can do this even if I were bedridden
because as long as I'm still reading the
journals and staying up to date I should
be good at this expert B might be in
Massachusetts choose to work Wednesday
to Friday and I'm do only 5 ok he says
and we get me as we need so this is the
thinking we haven't done it yet but if
we can get the payment pieced together
and if we can line up experts we can
create dozens of topic areas for DM T's
now the PhD lab directors are slowly
stepping forward to lead the DM T's I
think that the PhDs are worried that
they have clinical knowledge gaps and
somehow just because I came through and
got an MD that I must know a whole lot
more I will tell everyone that I did two
cases a month in my last year of
residency so I walked into my first job
having 24 Co AG cases behind me I've
done 50,000 plus now but that was all on
the job so the reality is that everyone
in medicine has knowledge gifts so if
you're worried about your own they're
easy enough to fill if you're not sure
what echocardiography does and how you
evaluate the valves of echocardiography
just go to youtube and start looking at
a few and figure out how a valve is
assessed using an echo and you will
continue to fill your your gaps by just
seeing cases now
there's another option here too because
we can't wait for the insurance company
to make it reasonable for pathologists
to change that'll be a decade or two and
if they're simply not a lot of PhDs out
there and and maybe the ones who are
working now isn't so the question is
could we team of folks who have a
doctorate in clinical laboratory science
like a farm deep work delivers five plus
years they know what a troponin test is
and they learn about how to give advice
to doctors who don't know which test to
pick and what the test results mean so
we started one here at utmb in Galveston
these are med techs have been working
for five years now they're gonna get a
doctoral degree and they have to come to
D mts then they have to create one of
their own their thesis work is around
the DMT and how effective it is and if
this all works we're graduating our
fruit there could be hundreds of EMTs
available in three to five years because
programs are popping up across the
country so the bottom line is somebody
has to help the patient we we've waited
a long time for something that now
everybody says we need so we're not
gonna wait even though we know it'll
come without creating DMD experts and I
do believe that the VCL S grads will be
a big component of the group let's talk
next about communication challenges so
connectivity is something that people
say we already have I mean I could put
my mobile phone in the middle of the
table at our DMT rounds and I've done
that many times
but what's ideal is to look at the
person for the expert consultation and I
can look at him or her on the screen and
it would be great if I can say let me
take the mouse and let me see if I can
find out the serum albumin so if you
have a system
that's familiar to us I will be able to
interrogate your record now I will say
that the issue of privacy is still
something we have to sort out to be able
to answer that question but but it
really enhances the work when we can
quickly get our questions answered so I
think if we're just talking to each
other the words only communicate some
portion of a message some people say
less than 10% visual clues help us
understand what's really important about
a case and and we also want to show more
than just the words I usually draw on
the board and somebody has a clot in the
popliteal artery I'll sketch a leg and
show you where the clot is and at rounds
yesterday we had somebody who had a
superior sagittal sinus thrombosis and I
asked the resident who was doing Guard
dmt could you pull up the veins in the
head and I pointed out where that where
that clot was and in addition yesterday
there was a new finding that I wanted to
show everybody about the platelet and
how binds some coagulation factors in
this new inhibitor and I had a reference
and they pulled it up on search we went
to figure four and I showed them what it
was so there's so much teaching every
day I learned something at rounds
because each one of these has new
information so there's a huge advantage
to being a DMT leader in terms of just
building and and and growing your
knowledge so that you're better at what
you do so we project a lot of de
lexicomp by the way we have somebody's
on ten meds and they're having a problem
bleeding well how do we know that that
isn't because of one of the meds or an
interaction between the beds so we did
that yesterday for example in one case
where we weren't really sure why the
patient was bleeding so all of that
shows up on the screen and if we just
have a phone in the middle of the room
that's hard to show so a lot of people
say all you have to do is take the
current tools and make them work well
tell you that this is
still a problem because the reliability
is not high enough
there's incorrect or incompatible
equipment or software and people on both
ends you know I have to have to know how
to use it so we have a room that looks
pretty fancy but I will tell you that
not all the equipment does what we
wanted to do each time so there there's
a real problem with making this much
better than it is and I will say that if
I if I ask someone who's asking for a
consult a question about a lab test what
was the serum albumin for example and it
takes five minutes to find it it was
inefficient these consults if we have
the right information and we do this all
the time are often answers we can give
in about two or three minutes and
explain it for another five so if we're
spending five minutes just trying to
find that albumin then we've lost our
momentum so the connectivity for all the
pieces is essential if it takes 19
keystrokes to get through a case it's
never gonna work you're gonna grab the
person who may not have seen fifty
thousand cases of something they might
have seen five but at least they're
standing next to you the problem is that
the patient is the unfortunate receiver
of not deep expert college but just the
person the knowledge of the person who
happens to be in the room the privacy
issues are big ones we have to address
those Jim violate any law it would be
great to get a 24/7 access to DMT
experts hopefully one day we can do that
for the ones that are most emergent we
haven't got through that yet it would
probably work if you're gonna be
awakened at night but but it may be
worth it if a patient's life hangs in
the balance and dual connection has to
be very reliable okay so let's talk
about the very last one and that's the
culture change so there is a culture
change we all know that a starting point
you do a B and C in your practice and
suddenly they're all outmoded
people are using methods D enf and the
person who knows how to do de NFS exists
successfully transitions and they like
him or her and the person who doesn't
falls off the edge and wants to retire
so this is true for every profession
absolutely every profession especially
health care but but there's always new
knowledge so in 1978 when I first
started learning collaboration 20 to 30
colloid tests no genetics it was all
bleeding no thrombosis
you took that so now it's 2018 can you
do what you need to do well look at this
dozens of anticoagulants now to pick
from hundreds of go egg tests lots of
genetics and thrombosis is bigger than
bleeding and in fact all the genetic
stuff is right in our faces there's
something now called the diagnostic
Odyssey where we do X Elmen alysus and
look at 23,500 genes now traits we may
be able to figure out why the floppy
baby is floppy and fix it so that they
don't pass away so who would have
thought that a total exome sequence to
evaluate a floppy baby made any sense
and now it's getting to be the standard
of care and an anatomic pathology it is
not microscopic review as you see on the
lower left right now we need genetics um
people have said that burb genes
relative to a diagnosis of acute my
acidic leukemia now exceeds 50 so if you
want to get information on prognosis and
the right chemo you need to know all of
that and that's what makes you good so
surgical pathology is moving big time
from ABC to BEF with artificial elegance
as is happening in radiology it could be
bigger on the left is a drawing of
somebody's torso that small is the navel
and the blue part is a liver and the red
spot is a mass and it's all electronic
so it knows the granularity size shape
and density and the image in the
electronic report says hepatoma
hepatitis so it can
at a hundred thousand times and then
learned what a epitome is and surely
it's going to do that for a nest of five
tumor cells in a liver biopsy so some
real trick for all of us in diagnostic
areas like path it is we be able to
integrate all the diagnostic information
and as you see on the lower right if we
don't delay the diagnosis we can spend
hundreds of dollars get the right tests
right away but as soon as we start
delaying the diagnosis without
complications on the far left or with
complications in the center we're
spending orders of magnitude more money
to get a diagnosis so the last slide is
your patient who do you want to take
care of you somebody who's seen fifty
thousand cases of what you got or
somebody who happens to be nearby
DMT has to be part of American medical
care it will not only save money it will
save lots of lives sixty five thousand
plus people died of a diagnostic err
every year in America and the DMT is one
option to try to prevent them so thank
you for your attention I appreciate the
fact that you're all knowledgeable about
this and I hope we can all work together
to scale up the DMT so that we can get
through these obstacles and make it
practical for all patients everything
thanks and thank you dr. la posada for
that informative presentation we'll now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions from our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just use that Q&A ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's take a look
at our questions from our viewers dr. la
posada are the obstacles to
consultations about labs also present in
other countries
so that's a that's a good question some
of them are and some of them are not I
think I owned that Laboratory Medicine
and anatomic pathology are different in
Europe in fact the laboratory medicine
is divided into subsections and people
trained for four years in clinical
chemistry for years in clinical
microbiology so the training is quite
different and I think that they they can
communicate better than we do there's
there's a reimbursement picture that is
very different in Europe so the people
who do anatomic pathology don't get paid
more than the people who do laboratory
medicine or clinical pathology as we
also call it so so the payment is
different and I think it allows more
diagnostic expertise to be brought to
the patient I would also say it's not so
adversarial what I learned in a recent
trip to Holland is that patients think
that doctors are more human and that
maybe they don't have a knowledge base
where they know absolutely everything
about medicine in themselves in their
own individuals so I part of it as a
perception of what the patient thinks
that a doctor and the urgency to create
a lawsuit so there are clear cultural
differences between the places that are
rarely globally for health care and us
in the United States and and we are not
ranked so high this next question is is
actually a two-part question the first
part is our technical advances with
communication likely to solve the
connectivity obstacle and why can't you
just use a telephone yes so this was
part of the talk I won't say that in
Galveston we've had now two meetings the
third one is coming up in March March
5th and 6th if you want to come to gala
for the the third diagnostic management
team meeting we're gonna talk about all
lease obstacles and and in one of them
we had somebody come who is a
technological expert who showed pictures
of the devices and said you can use this
one this one this one they all exist I
think as I mentioned the problem is
reliability think about a procedure an
appendectomy what only good 90% of the
time so that means one out of ten people
who could just have an inflamed appendix
snipped off and go back to work ends up
dying you can't have a 90 percent
success rate for things that we do in
medicine it and when when you cut you
can't see the person and the consult
goes on too long it's simply not gonna
work so we have to pay a lot of
attention to connectivity and and we're
really focusing on that issue in a way
that everybody who those who are not
technically savvy can just press an on
button and somehow they're connected to
an expert absolutely dr. lapis Auto
would you like to provide our viewers
with some closing remarks I yes I think
that the diagnostic management team
concept has now passed the point where
there is a answer about the need
everybody needs there was a time when
people would aren't know to take care of
my patients the report issued in 2015 on
diagnostic error which Joan that there
are as many people dying every year from
diagnostic air in the United States this
is debts as died in the Second World War
remarkable and we're not talking about
it really shows how much doctors don't
know
and not because they're not smart or
they're not working hard enough there's
just too much to know and therefore
there's all these preventable deaths
that we that we can eliminate that with
the knowledge brought to the public in
2015 the diagnostic error is this big a
problem it is time to address these
obstacles and quickly snap the pieces
into place this is often the way it goes
things trickle along get more and more
important than how all of a sudden they
become essential and I think that the
next few years are going to be the years
where we wonder how in the heck that we
take care of our patients when we
couldn't call up somebody and say what
does that result yes doctor la posada
thank you so much for keynote
presentation today and for your
important research I also like to think
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February 2019 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when the webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye